i want you to think about this logic
that i just went through okay
how i literally went from like the most
basic level
i only know the gradient i only know the
intercepts and i'm going to take
advantage of what i know about quantum
geometry
to arrive at a formula i'd like you to
have a go
deriving the formula for point gradient
form you know what the formula is
okay it's not complicated it's not very
different to this one either
how would you start from the most basic
fact that you've known
which is just a point adjust the
gradient
and arrive at the familiar result i'll
give you a few minutes to have a think
about it
we're doing point gradient form now and
you can see i'm going to go about this
in a very
similar way to how i went through
gradient
intercepts right remember for this
i began with the intercept that was zero
b okay
i don't have an intercept at this point
i have some point
off in space anywhere so i'll start with
that i pass through this point
i'll just define any of the points on
here and i'll call that
i'll call that the point that my line
must pass through
okay once i've done that in order to
have a gradient well a gradient is a
comparison between two points at the
very least
right so therefore i need this second
point up here and i'll call that x y
just like i call this x y that
represents
this is a really important idea i'm just
going to tease it now i'll tell you the
name of it
and we will deal with the topic at the
end of the year this is called a locus
right locus
it's this idea
of a set of points that all behave in a
certain way they all
follow the same rules okay so
yeah it's another way of looking at
these familiar equations okay we're
going to deal with that as a proper
topic later on but just say
in a few months time when you're like oh
you mentioned this thing it's like that
why are you talking about bugs in class
that eat crops no they're not locusts
blockers okay so it is like
now that i have a point i could define
its gradient
right like soda okay and it doesn't take
you that long to realize
okay your rise is going to be y minus y
one
right and your run is going to be x
minus x one
so i'm playing exactly the same trick i
had before i've got y minus y
one x minus x one that's equal to
the gradient by definition right that's
how i constructed the diagram
so therefore just one line there voila
is our point gradient form that's it
okay now as students pointed out it's
not really worth a whole extra diagonal
for it
if instead of passing through one point
right and having a gradient i get given
two points
which by the way is exactly the same as
being given a gradient right if you're
given another point
that that defines the grading for you
all you need to do
is take this guy here right so this is
this is in its current
position it's point gradient form
all you need to do to turn this into two
point is to change the gradient
into how you work out the gradient when
you have two points
namely rise over
run right that's m isn't it that's our
formula for m
now that's being multiplied by this and
this is what's on the left hand side
so all i need to do is see oh look this
x minus x one let's let's group the x's
together
and this one let's group the y's
together okay so
if i divide through i'm gonna get this
y minus y one
and f from point gradient four now
you've got two point four
okay they are the same thing these are
all the same thing just seen through
different lenses
okay worth mentioning occasionally you
will see
instead of y minus y1 on the top and y2
minus y1 at the bottom
occasionally you'll see that flipped
upside down right does it matter
no because if you've got that flick
you'll have this flipped as well it's
the same fraction
okay um that's right okay so
whichever form you've got it in so long
as you have everything matched up
the way that i tended to write it when i
was in year 11 is i did all of the y
ones and x ones first
i write minus y one minus by one because
i know that's the same
all right minus x one minus x one
because that's the same and then i just
put the rest of it wherever i want
really it depends on what you're after
okay the last one uh
two intercept form is the least common
but in some ways
it's the most useful so let's let's talk
through it
i'm not gonna um
leave you to your own devices on this
one because it's a bit trickier
too in december okay
let's have a go are there three points
there's just two you just need the x and
y x
y
oh right anyway
so i'm gonna derive for you to intercept
form it's a brilliantly simple um
equation once you get there and it's
very very practical as you'll see
shortly
um but one of the problems that
immediately presents us with is i'm
going to use
general form which you know
i'm going to use general form as my
mechanism to derive like it's my
starting point
to derive this okay so immediately like
i have letters that i can't use
and i need to find okay two intercept
form i need to define
a y-intercept and an x in the set so i
have to give them some names
some values okay so to try and avoid
ambiguity
by calling this b but there's already a
b there or calling it capital b
and lowercase b which is just as
confusing um
i'm just going to call this beta and
alpha okay i know we normally reserve
that for angles but
there's just not enough letters that you
guys are very familiar with that i can
use so i'm just gonna go with that
okay now if i've got a line and by
definition i've said
it passes through
these two intercepts okay just remember
back to what we did um
the point brain sorry the gradient
intercept form
those two points those three intercepts
are coordinates they have coordinates
right
what are the coordinates of each point
what's this one it's zero here
right zero comma theta what about this
one alpha
alpha comma zero right okay
now if i know the points on the line
that satisfy
that line that means that they satisfy
the equation right
so i can take this sum it into here i
can take this
something to there and those statements
should both be true because the points
are on those
on that line does that make sense so i'm
going to get two equations out of this
let's
do it right we'll take uh let's do the x
intercept first okay
so that's x is going to be
alpha y is going to be
zero plus
that all right okay uh now let's just
tie this up a little bit this is
a alpha plus c equals zero now
this point right what am i trying to
work towards
okay there's so many letters here it's
easy to get confused
alpha and beta are some known values
you know what the intercepts are right
they might be
three and five or eighteen and two
hundred okay but the point is they're
numbers you know what they are
a b and c they are the unknowns
that's what i'm trying to get rid of
okay um so
i want to solve for a b and c now
for reasons that will become clear as we
go through rather than make c the
subject i'm going to make a the subject
so i've got a alpha equals
minus c right so maybe a the subject
i've got minus c on alpha you're happy
with that
so i have a value for a now whatever
that is okay
if i repeat the process this was my
first equation based on the x-intercept
if i repeat the process for the
y-intercept i'm going to have
x is zero so a times zero
plus help me out here b b times
beta and there's still that constant
flying around over there
okay i'm going to simplify exactly the
same way and i'm going to end up with
dot dot dot
b equals minus c on
beta okay it's literally exactly the
same thing
so now i have a value for a i've got a
value for b i'm going to put them back
into my original equation
so that i don't have a's or b's anymore
okay uh what am i going to have there's
a
so minus c on alpha x
minus c on beta y
plus c you're happy with that just a
straight substitution
back into my general form okay now you
can perhaps see why i chose to get rid
of a and b
because now look at what i've got here
remember number one this is
all equal to zero right uh and number
two you've got all these c's here so
what would you like me to do to simplify
this
i'm going to divide through i'll go one
step better than c i'm going to divide
through by minus
c okay just make it a tiny tiny bit
later all my c's are going to vanish and
all my signs are going to flip
so i'm going to get 1 on alpha x one on
bigger
one like this one okay
now i could stop there to be honest um
but the
you know just like there's conventions
and that kind of thing this
traditionally is not where we stop
we traditionally stop one step further
and that right there is two intercept
form
okay so if you might have seen this
before i'm not knowing what it was
if i know what the two intercepts
i said three and five before okay so if
i want the equation of a line
that passes through uh what do i know
three over here and five over here
then its equation is going to be x on
three
plus y on five equals one how would you
convert that to general form
i would multiply by the something that
will eliminate both denominators so i'd
go
5x plus 3y equals 15.
and then to be a bit cheap i just moved
that 15 over to the other side
done okay um
in exactly the same way suppose i did
one general form suppose i want to go
from here to here
and get um the gradient and it's well i
already know it's y intercepts right how
am i going to do that
i want y as a subject don't i right so i
guess i'll multiply it by five
that would make this five over three x
plus y
equals five and then i just rearrange
minus 5 over 3x which sure enough
that looks like minus 5 over 3 doesn't
it you can see how ingenious this is
because like why does it work if i were
to put in x equals 0
x equals 0 that's how i find the y
intercept isn't it right well watch what
happens when x equals 0
this guy just disappears right
so therefore y equals beta which is what
what we defined from the first place and
in exactly the same way if i let y
equal zero this thing disappears so you
get x equals alpha
okay now the reason why i love this i
said this is a very practical form
is because you know just as frequently
like if you're going to graph something
one of the things you're known to have
to put onto the graph
that you draw is the intercepts you must
put those on that's like the most
important feature
right so if i just magic up some you
know some equation like this
two x minus three y plus eight
or zero okay how do i work out the
intercepts i could do my x equals my y
kind of thing but how can i take
advantage of this
here's what i'll do i want my x and y on
this side and i want a constant on the
other side
does that make sense so let's let's just
make this a little bit neater let's do
that okay
i'm going to add 8 to both sides so 2x
minus 3y
equals 8. okay what do i want on the
right hand side not just the constant
i want 1 eight so i'll divide through by
eight so this is going to become x
on four minus three x y equals one you
happy with that
i've already found my x-intercept bam
it's sitting right there
this one this one takes a little more
work but not that much
in order to get that on the denominator
i just need to flip it upside down
right so this is actually y over minus
eight
over three can you see that i've taken
the reciprocal so it goes on the bottom
bam there's my i'm not bad man